[Música]
buenas noches
bienvenidos hijos del rock and roll
dibuje una puerta violeta en la pared
en un lugar de la mancha de cuyo nombre
no quiero acordarme
quizás porque mi niñez sigue jugando en
tu playa
contamíname
mezcla té conmigo
que cada uno de lo que recibe y luego
recibe lo que da
estos son algunas canciones hay otras
que seguro que hemos cantado bailado
gritado hasta el amanecer o frases de
algunos libros que hemos leído y luego
hemos subrayado y luego más adelante
hemos compartido en facebook instagram
no sé quién no ha leído una frase oído
una canción o visto una secuencia de una
película de televisión o se ha quedado
delante de una obra durante un rato en
un museo y no le ha removido algo a
quien no le ha inspirado a quien no se
le ha dado la valentía para a chapala
ante un vagón para adelante o no le ha
hecho ni imaginar que otros mundos son
posibles
11 son 7
quien me lo iba a decir
a quien no le evoca esta frase aquí en
el de boca por no sé alguno
algún recuerdo de su vida a mí desde
luego la vida me ha cambiado
completamente lo digo
vamos a partir del paradigma gale de que
vosotros a mí me identifica
automáticamente con esa canción vale
vale ya estamos presentados nos
relajamos
porque yo porque me dio a conocer ante
el gran público
pero yo creo que también es por otra
cosa creo que porque la cultura nos
conecta nos vincula emocionalmente con
cosas lo creo firmemente
tal vez esta frase de esta canción pues
no sé
por ahí recuerde a vuestra infancia por
ahí un poquito manda la adolescencia
cuando erais jóvenes
no sé a los juegos trae un recuerdo
agradable oa lo mejor os provoca rechazo
también puede pasar sobre todo por el
final de las series
no lo escribí yo vale
yo cante la canción eso sí sí pero antes
de cantar la canción pasaron muchas
cosas pasaron unas cuantas cosas que me
llevaron hasta allí
y yo fui un niño aquí en málaga un niño
con unos padres muy aficionados al
teatro a la danza la música a la cultura
en general
o sea imagina el primer concierto al que
me llevaron mis padres a mi a mi hermana
con 4 o 5 años fue el bienvenidos de
miguel ríos aquí en la malagueta yo
flipé claro flip después ese niño ese
niño que iba al teatro con sus padres
desde pequeñito se quedaba fascinado con
la magia que se producía encima del
escenario y como el público reía y
lloraba estaba en vilo
así que ese gusanillo de la infancia
pues fue fue despertando en un impulso
mayor y al final terminé dedicándome
profesionalmente a ello
y si miro atrás la verdad si me
sorprende muchísimo para empezar y luego
me doy cuenta de que
de que la cultura me ha hecho mejor
persona me ha convertido en
en alguien mejor y hoy estoy aquí para
contaros un secreto
vuestras vidas también pueden mejorar a
través de la cultura
o puede convertir en mejores personas
estoy seguro de ella y tengo argumentos
y yo los voy a comentar
pero yo creo que la cultura es riqueza
para el alma y para las emociones porque
porque pone palabras a esas emociones
hay veces que nos pasa algo dentro que
no sabemos muy bien que es ay que me
está pasando por dios que me está
pasando y de pronto escuchas una canción
lees un libro que es una obra de teatro
ves una película dice a otra me pasara
esto
el ejemplo típico cuando te enamora o
cuando te separaban que todas las
canciones hablan de ti así esta canción
habla de mí está también no mari carmen
no está escrita para ti no
es que hay alguien en algún momento de
la historia de la vida que se ha
dedicado a ello que se va a escribir y a
poner un código ahí para que tú luego lo
asimile es como tuyo
y no te sientas tan sólo tan sola y que
ahorre una pasta en psicólogos además
luego además la cultura nos hace vivir
vivir experiencias que no podríamos
vivir de otra manera si no hablo no
hablo solo por mí en la parte de actor
que me toca sería sería imposible estar
todo el día intentando donjuán
no hablo de vivir una odisea en el
espacio'
y hablarle a una pelota de voley en una
isla después de naufragar hablo hablo de
agobiarte porque no puedes ayudar a
salir a esa criada en el cuento de la
criada desde eso hablo después también
la cultura
nos ayuda a dar pasos importantes en
nuestra vida yo estoy convencido de ello
en 2010 yo saqué un disco se llama
viejos conocidos que lo produje yo fue
después del boom de todos los serranos y
demás un dijo que produje yo y fue un
esfuerzo titánico además nos fue bien sé
que no habéis comprado no os preocupéis
bien a mí aquí no me dejó exhausto y
deje de componer un tiempo dije mira yo
no
no puedo más no estoy como abajo
bien hace unos años pedro guerra me
invitó a un concierto que daba en
libertad 8 en el mítico garito madrileño
de calle libertad que era un concierto
fue un concierto precioso un concierto
de pedro con la guitarra solamente bien
pues el frank que entró a ese concierto
no no fue el frank que salió del
concierto era otra persona o sea me
había cambiado completamente y ese día
decidí que iba a volver a componer
empecé a la guitarra otra vez me
puse a componer y que hace unos meses
sacaba un disco
esto es promoción también
pero dais cuenta de cosas de la
importancia que puede tener
la cultura puede puede darnos eso tan
ansiado que buscamos que es la felicidad
hace hace unos días leí un estudio que
ha salido de la universidad goldsmiths
de londres que dice que ir a un
concierto aumenta la esperanza de vida
cómo te quedas
o sea que esta casa
[Música]
y señor aumenta la esperanza de vida
dice el estudio que 20 minutos en un
concierto aumenta en un 21% ojo la
sensación de bienestar en un 21 21 por
ciento personal cifra igual nos cobraban
viva por eso no sea
este estudio dice más dice que se llama
si eres reincidentes y que va a un
concierto los otros ya lo loco sin
mesura tu esperanza de vida puede
aumentar hasta nueve años
hoy quien no quiere vivir nueve años más
hay un poco de escepticismo por ahí
quizá
bueno tengo mi segundo argumento el
primero el alma pero dice bueno mira yo
es que lo del alma no bueno la educación
cultura es riqueza por la importancia
por la importancia y por su aportación a
la educación
por qué por qué por qué nos pone en la
piel de otras personas básicamente la
cultura nos ayuda a salir de nuestra
realidad de dejar de mirarnos el ombligo
propio y de pronto irnos al ombligo de
otras personas que tienen otros
problemas y eso nos ayuda a lo mejor a
ser más solidarios más tolerantes nos
ayuda a tener menos prejuicios y nos
ayuda a empatizar que es algo
de verdad que yo
me encanta esa idea de las cosas que
aprendido desde las que más disfruto y
empatizar dice los expertos que hay dos
maneras de aprender una de las maneras
es estudiando
y la otra es escuchando a gente que sabe
sobre algún tema entonces tú lo escucha
y aprende y yo a mí me gustaría incluir
que consumiendo consumiendo cultura
aprendes sobre otras realidades hay un
ejemplo muy reciente que ha ocurrido
hace muy poquitos días en la gala de los
goya la película campeones de javier
fesser lo que ocurrió con esta película
es maravilloso el discurso deje sus
vidas ya ni te cuento pero la película
es que de pronto nos han puesto la
realidad de la discapacidad delante de
las capacidades diferentes como ellos
decían con muy buen criterio delante y
yo creo que no sea alguien que no tenga
ningún contacto con gente en esas
condiciones yo creo que esa película le
abre los ojos de una manera maravillosa
o sea que efectivamente ponerse en la
piel de otros pues nos hace ser menos
egoístas y nos hacen intentar trabajar
por mejorar la vida de otras personas en
nuestro día a día y eso al final nos va
a producir una satisfacción maravillosa
hay escepticismo todavía por ahí
bueno tengo un tercer argumento que es
en el material la cultura es riqueza por
el dinero para un país
a la economía cultural cada vez tiene
mayor protagonismo y esto no lo dice no
lo digo yo lo dice la unesco y la
denomina economía naranja dice que
ninguna sociedad puede prosperar sin
cultura y sin ella cualquier desarrollo
no es sostenible así que
que yo no soy experto en cifras pero voy
a dar algunas
en el año 2017
fueron en los conciertos recaudaron
conciertos de música en vivo recaudaron
300 millones de euros
las artes escénicas recaudaron los más
de 200 millones de euros se vendieron
más de 100 millones de tickets de cine y
13 millones de turistas extranjeros de
los 82 que vienen a visitarnos lo
hicieron por motivos culturales
no soy experto en cifras pero estas
cifras la verdad bastante bien
esto tiene esto apunta bien en 2013 no
nos juntamos un grupo de actores y
montamos una compañía se llama phil wood
con una obra de teatro se llama phil
wood y nos dimos cuenta de que la
cultura nunca estaba sobre sobre la mesa
del debate político y entonces decidimos
hacer nuestra aportación a la economía
naranja con un vídeo que pongo ya
genera riqueza del teatro eso nos
preguntamos nosotros así que en 2013
fundamos una compañía de teatro y nos
propusimos auto producir la obra film de
alistair vito
empezamos por crear empleo para seis
actores un director una ayudante de
dirección y una traductora luego llegó
el montaje que ocupó a dos actores más
una directora y un equipo de rodaje una
empresa de producción director de
iluminación escenógrafa músico
diseñadora de vestuario y una empresa de
distribución de teatro imprenta tiendas
de ropa y de muebles publicista
fotógrafo y diseñador de web estrenamos
y empezamos la gira y la familia creció
dos técnicos transporte para la
escenografía dos agencias de
comunicación un cámara y editor de vídeo
otro fotógrafo una sola obra de teatro
ha creado más de 30 empleos directos y
eso sin contar los empleos indirectos
trenes y aerolíneas empresas de alquiler
de coches peajes gasolinas cafeterías
hoteles medios de comunicación
plataforma de venta de entradas el
mantenimiento de los puestos de trabajo
de los teatros que visitamos
bares y restaurantes cargadores de
móviles olvidados en los dos años de
vida de facebook tuvimos más de 100
funciones y 60.000 espectadores pagaron
su entrada con su 21% de iva incluido
para venir al teatro
es como si todas ávila o cuenca o
segovia o huesca hubiera venido a vernos
en los peores años de crisis de españa
feelgood ha generado y movido entre
salarios impuestos seguridad social
beneficios más de 400 mil euros a ver si
al final va a resultar que la cultura no
es un gasto sino una inversión aunque
después de tantos números sin duda la
mejor cuenta de resultados el mayor
beneficio es el superávit que el teatro
aporta a nuestras almas la cultura es
algo excepcional no es sólo ocio y
entretenimiento la cultura y la creación
son un referente primordial en la
formación del ser humano
y lo mejor lo mejor lo mejor que tiene
la cultura es compartirla y es verdad
pues de primamos esta fiera condición
esta furia esta ambición por si alguna
vez soñamos y si haremos pues estamos el
mundo tan singular que el vivir solo es
soñar y la experiencia me enseña que el
hombre que vive sueña lo que es hasta
despertar nace el rey y vive con este
engaño mandando disponiendo y gobernando
y este aplauso que recibe prestado en el
viento escribe y en cenizas le convierte
la muerte desdicha fuerte que hay de
quien intentar reinar viendo que ha de
despertar en el sueño de la muerte sueña
el rico en sus riquezas que más cuidados
le ofreces hoy al pobre que padece su
miseria y su pobreza señal que a medrar
empieza a soñar que agravia y ofende
señal que afana y pretende y el mundo en
conclusión todos sueñan lo que son
aunque ninguno lo entiende yo sueño que
estoy aquí de estas prisiones cargado y
soñé que en otro estado más y sojero me
vi que es la vida a un frenesí que es la
vida una ilusión una sombra una ficción
y el mayor bien es pequeño que toda la
vida es sueño y los
sueños son
[Aplausos]